all right hi everybody can everyone hear
me okay see hey I'm Evan this is my
first strange Luke it's amazing why are
we talking about scheduling well if you
read serious documentation by serious
people building high-performance systems
you can find a variety of statements
along these lines suggesting vaguely
disquieting way that scheduling overhead
can negatively impact the performance of
highly concurrent programs so you can
find this in engine X you can find this
in my sequel Docs and you can find
statements to the effect that thread
context switching is somehow
intrinsically expensive but these
statements are not quantified or
justified in this documentation which is
fine because that's not their job but as
a performance engineer this makes me
kind of uneasy so scheduling which for
the purposes of this talk means
multiplexing a lot of tasks on to a few
cores a few processors a priori is kind
of a black box like you can write a lot
of concurrent code without needing to
worry deeply about the internals of the
Linux kernel scheduler or the runtime
scheduler if you are using a language
that has its own concurrency primitives
so it's this black box and the claim is
that it can potentially negatively
affect our programs performance so this
is not good I don't like black boxes
that make things slower in mysterious
ways so there's a pretty natural set of
questions that we can ask about this the
scheduling business so how expensive is
a context switch intrinsically when the
go language authors say it's slow what
what do they mean can we measure it or
do we just have to take their word that
it's slow and how does the Linux kernel
scheduler work anyways when you switch
from one chrome tab to the next or spawn
a new thread what's going on under the
hood and what about user space
schedulers so languages like go and
Erlang in Haskell have their own
concurrency primitives that are sort of
like operating system threads but not
actually operating systems threads so
those are scheduled by the language
runtime how does that work is it somehow
fundamentally different are there common
design patterns that all these scheduler
implementations follow and do they make
different trade-offs do they target
different performance use cases and how
do they do so so that's what I like to
explore in this talk by doing a few like
pretty basic experiments and a little
bit of experimentation and source diving
so to start off let's talk about
scheduling in kernel-space
I'd like to start this discussion by
talking about how we can actually
estimate kernel context switch cost so
you have a processor it runs Linux I'm
only going to talk about Linux in this
presentation sorry but if you're
initially running task a on a core like
a chrome tab and then you switch to task
B which is something else I don't know
it's a slog whatever there's some
intrinsic costs to that operation and
measuring the duration of a context
switch is probably the first heuristic
we can establish for how much
concurrency can our system support if
the context switch takes 10 microseconds
we'll never be able to run more than a
hundred thousand threads on a core
because we will spend all of our time
context switching so maybe it's okay if
context switching accounts for some
reasonably significant part of our
effective workload and highly concurrent
scenarios but it's probably not okay if
that's all that we're doing so there's a
classical approach to estimating the
intrinsic direct cost of a context
switch it's playing ping-pong we'll set
up a scenario where we do a bunch of
context switches and as little other
work as we can so for example you start
a thread thread a you start a thread
thread B you connect them with two pipes
when you have thread a right to thread B
over one pipe thread B will wait and
read it then write back over the other
pipe thread a will wait and so on so
that so what has to happen is that you
end up switching back and forth between
these threads effectively as quickly as
the operating system can do it makes
sense so in C the implementation of such
a worker thread might look something
like this
now I can't really write see I try it
doesn't work fortunately I don't have to
this is actually a built-in benchmark in
the Linux kernel source tree you can run
it with perf bench Skype and you can
pass - T to say two threads now two
processes it doesn't really matter so
you can try that out on my laptop it
takes about four and a half seconds to
do a million pipe operations what does
that mean so it tells us four point four
nine microseconds per operation and that
gives us an upper bound on the direct
cost of a thread context switch that
upper bound is actually 2.25
microseconds because what the authors of
this benchmark are calling an op is a
read and done it right so there are two
context which is if you think about it
it makes sense promise cool so that's
pretty good heuristic is that our final
answer
no so you can't actually trust a
benchmark if you just run it and don't
undertake at least some minimal effort
to analyze it while it's running there
will be no more dead poetry in this talk
I promise but there's a serious point
here which is that we're running a bunch
sorry
oh I have no idea it's a two gigahertz
processor you can do the math great so
sorry the question was how many
instructions does that correspond to and
that's two microseconds divided by two
gigahertz I don't know a bunch so that's
ranking right so so we have this
benchmark that's that's doing thread
ping-pong and we have a mental model of
what it's doing it's running for it a
and then executing a context switch and
then running thread B and then running
thread a so how well does this map to
reality well we can find out with a tool
called perf sket what's perfect good
it's another purse of command perf is a
lot of sub commands what persica does is
it records scheduler events and then can
show you an output a timeline of context
switches wakeup latency etc seems like
something that might be applicable to a
discussion about scheduling so you're on
perf schedule cord over our benchmark
and get basically a dump of everything
that happens in the scheduler while we
were running this this is really dense
but we can highlight one thing we're
switching from something called skid
pipe okay that that sounds good
to something called the swapper up
what's the swapper it's basically what
the kernel runs when idling so that
doesn't really map to this mental model
very well what's going on so I ran this
on my laptop my laptop is recently
modern it has multiple cores the
scheduler sees thread a is doing a bunch
of work thread B is doing a bunch of
work okay I'm gonna put thread a on this
one core and thread B over on this other
core but that introduces a net slow down
into this benchmark because every single
write to a pipe and then read from it
introduces a cross core wake up and it
turns out that that actually adds some
overhead to this benchmark I'm partly
because waking up from the idle State
a little bit more expensive than the
direct contact switch and partly because
the cross-court communication degrades
cache performance so let's turn the
benchmark slightly differently I depend
all the tests to core zero it's twice as
fast all right
active benchmarking so you didn't just
go at the first result we saw we used a
tool to analyze the internals of the
benchmark verified that we were running
a benchmark which X for the
correspondent reasonably well to our
mental model of what it is suing and now
I have a more plausible number so we've
learned something the direct cost of a
thread context which is around one
microsecond on this machine with lots of
caveats sorry you have the question yes
these are two threads in the same
process numbers are slightly different
in this benchmark if you switch between
two processes and two threads the
question was about whether this is a
thread context switch or a process
context switch in this talk we will
mostly be talking about thread context
switches in a highly multi-threaded
single process program from the
perspective of the Linux kernel there's
not that much difference there are
slight variations in the numbers that
you get does that does that make sense
cool so so you're on perf bench that
pipe - t-that - team at run - threads
not run - processes but they get
different pits so so we have a number
and we have some metal lessons
benchmarking is tricky we can't just run
random experiments we need some level of
introspection into the scheduler and for
that it's helpful to have some idea of
how the scheduler actually works so
let's talk about the internals of the
Linux kernel scheduler so you know up
here it has to do two things
it has to preempt misbehaving tasks and
it has to prioritize important tasks
all right we can do this I so can't
write C but we'll try so keep a list of
running tasks and whenever we want to
schedule will iterate through that list
pick the task with the lowest count down
to run next and then for each other
runnable test test will decrement the
count down
counting down higher priority tasks
faster so over several iterations high
priority tasks will effectively move to
the front of the line then if there's an
X test that we should switch to well
switch to it this is actually how the
Linux kernel scheduler worked in 1995
all right it was 75 lines of code not 15
I cut out some stuff about timers but
still not that complicated
today it's a lot in our lair in addition
to preemption and prioritization the
Linux kernel is expected to support a
notion of fairness it's effective it's
expected to scale to multi-core machines
it's it should be power efficient it
should support resource constraints like
C groups so you can run your fancy-pants
docker containers or whatever and so on
and so forth and as a result it's a lot
bigger but there are a few salient
design principles that we can highlight
in the current implementation of the
Linux kernel scheduler it's called the
completely fair scheduler there are
other scheduling policies in the kernel
like real time and FIFO we're not going
to talk about those this is the default
probably what's happening if you're
running a concurrent program in the
Linux kernel so in general scheduling
happens on a curb port on a purikura
basis and we'll talk about inter CPU
load balancing later why is this it's
because a single global data structure
that's frequently read and updated tends
to introduce contention and severely
degrade cache performance so this allows
the kernel to scheduler to scale well to
64 128 core machines now on each core we
maintain a run queue of runnable tasks
which isn't actually a queue or it's
sort of a queue it's a red-black tree
the
ordered by task view runtime what the
runtime is virtual around time which is
effectively real task runtime / task
wait
so high priority tasks have their view
runtimes scaled down as tests run they
accumulate if you you're on time
whenever it's time to execute a task
switch the scheduler simply pulls the
leftmost task off the rank you and runs
it next concurrently preempted or new or
woken tasks go on to the run queue
before they can be rescheduled so the
run queue is effectively a timeline of
future tasks execution and tasks are
guaranteed a fair allocation of runtime
what do I mean by that
okay so if you look at this line here
the middle line we ran tests a which
started out with a low V runtime then
switch back to task C but we can see
that task a still has lower V runtimes
and task E so it will run before task E
and what this means is that over time
each task gets a fair share of processor
time which is not true if you apply a
simple scheduling policy like FIFO or
LIFO or you just round-robin through
through all the tasks so it's reasonable
to ask what actually prompts a task
switch to things pretty much the running
test blocks and explicitly calls into
the scheduler hey I'm going to have to
wait for something colonel you can
schedule a me off and run something else
or the running task is forcibly
preempted because it exhausted its
schedule in quantum this is sort of an
intricate and cooled answer I'd like to
talk a little bit about how preemption
works unsurprisingly it's driven by a
hardware timer every so many
milliseconds timer goes off interrupt
handler interrupt handler routes this
timer to schedule our code which checks
if it's time to reschedule the current
task
prompting directly from this handler
could cause funny stuff to happen if we
were in a nested kernel control path
where we were already handling some sort
of other interrupts so instead the
interrupt handler instead of directly
switching tasks sets a flag in the tasks
thread info struct signaling that
rescheduling is due to happen hey this
flag is set then when it's safe to
switch contexts on the irq exit path we
check that flag and if we need to we do
whatever cleanup work and then call
schedule schedule is unsurprisingly the
course scheduler function it DQ's the
next test to run in queues the
preemptory one swaps out their processor
processor state registers and what have
you does whatever clean up it needs to
and then starts running the next task a
little intricate generally works cool so
thus far we have a scheduler that
supports preemption prioritization and
fairness let's talk a bit about how its
scales to many core systems so like I
mentioned per process run queues limit
contention and and cache thrashing but
they can lead to a severely unbalanced
test distribution so in this picture
core zero has a bunch of tasks core one
only has one core one is underutilized
so each core periodically does a simple
load balancing procedure but fair
balancing is tricky say task C has
higher weight meaning higher priority
than tasks a B and D if we just looked
at the run queue length o thread core
has a bunch of tasks core one only has
one okay I'm going to move some tests
from core zero to core one then we would
unfairly deprive the high priority task
of its do run time we could try
balancing based on total task weight so
all right core zero has each each test
is weight time there are three of them
it has weight 30 core one has one really
high priority test with weight 100 but
if the high priority test frequently
sleeps this ends up being really
efficient because core one could idle
for long periods of time instead the
kernel does something or like
balancing uses a load metric based on a
combination of task weight and CPU
utilization to ensure that high priority
tasks get their fair share of time but
cores are efficiently utilized even in
the presence of processes that
frequently sleep wake up to wake up
so at this point you might be thinking
it's kind of complicated I have more
questions how am I going to answer them
like what about the power efficiency
stuff that you talked about and I'm
actually going to dive into in this talk
so you could listen to some bozo blather
on and believe what he says you could
stare really hard at the source code and
try and figure it out or and I recommend
this approach use F trace the function
tracer this is the coolest thing how
many people here have heard of F trace
alright so that's cool
so f trace is this amazing technology it
dynamically traces all almost all
function entry and return points in the
kernel so when disabled it has almost
zero overhead you turn it on it has
overhead obviously it has overhead but
you can see a call graph of every single
function that if the kernel is calling
that's amazing
it's a Linux tool it's kind of gnarly to
use you mount this debug filesystem and
then you put cat some stuff to it but
you can read about it on the internet
it's not too hard to figure out and you
can answer questions like what's the
code path through the scheduler look
like alright we call schedule and then
we do a bunch of stuff or what happens
when you call read on a pipe well you
could grep through the source code and
try and find pipe read or you could just
write a little program that reads from a
pipe run F trace all right it's it's
doing some stuff and eventually
scheduling makes sense so my
recommendation for diving deep into the
internals of the Linux kernel schedule
are really the Linux kernel at all is
use F trace to build a function call
graph and figure out what's actually
happening on your system way easier than
trying to do it in your head with the
northa source tree pretty cool so the
completely fair scheduler its performant
scalable robe
traceable and if story new let's switch
gears and talk about scheduling in
userspace
so there are good reasons why some
language runtimes don't simply have fall
back to native operating system threads
and instead offer you different
concurrency primitives these are
languages like go Erlang Haskell others
you might want to target different
performance characteristics let's say
you want concurrency constructs in your
program and you want 10 million FM you
can't have 10 million threads we already
saw that because the context switch
takes 1 microsecond you just be context
switching you might want to decouple
concurrency from memory usage once
severe limitation of operating system
threads is that stack size is fixed at
creation time and in practice this tends
to be the bottleneck to creating lots
and lots of threads before context
switching you have a million threads
each one has a megabyte of stack space
alright you need a terabyte of memory
that's expensive and you might want to
support manage memory runtimes by
integrating the scheduler with the
garbage collector but we won't really
talk about this in this talk but it is a
legitimate use case this is part of how
go achieves very low latency garbage
collection times so so language runtimes
implement their own schedulers on top of
the operating system baseline are these
schedulers fundamentally different from
the kernel scheduler do they share
significant design patterns let's take a
look I want to look at two languages
when is go the other is Erlang so let's
talk about go and go how many people
here of program dingo ok cool good
number so and go code runs and go
routines which are sort of like threads
ostensibly more lightweight and managed
by the language runtime they're supposed
to be very cheap to create and dispose
of go routines are multiplexed onto OS
threads in a process called m2n
scheduling so you
have relatively through relatively few
operating system threads at any point
and a whole lot of go routines and the
language runtime takes care of managing
it for you so the claim is that
rescheduling agar routine is much
cheaper than rescheduling a thread so
what you've done if an unkind again mean
by much cheaper
does anybody have a guess how you could
find out yeah ping pong so we can do
this and go go has a concurrency
primitives called a channel that lets
you send data between guru teams it's
kind of like a pipe so this is a crude
heuristic we're not going to deep dive
into this benchmark but we can write a
simple go program that spawns to worker
threads with channels between them and
plays ping pong back and forth run it
alright point to microseconds per switch
that's way faster they were right that's
not surprising there Donovan and
Kernighan so what's the go scheduler
doing let's take a look so you go
runtime state is basically described by
three data structures there's an M which
represents an operating system thread a
G and which represents a go routine and
a P which represents general context for
executing go code each P contains a
queue of runnable go routines so so far
this is not that different from Linux we
have some data structure per core and it
has a run queue if things are going to
run next in a context switch time the
next go routine is pulled off the run
queue and run so on an end core machine
we end up with up to n threads
concurrently executing go code still not
that different however there's no
regularly scheduled interpeduncular
balancing instead goo routines which
were preempted or blocked insist calls
go on to a special global run Q and a P
which becomes idle can steal work from
another P all right these go routines
are mine now
finally a separate system on thread
implements pee handoff if an M blocks an
assist call what do I mean by that all
right we're running go code the go code
is green and then it executes SAS this
call it's going to read a ginormous file
from disk and then it blocks in the SIS
call this disclosed yellow what happens
all the other and go routines that were
scheduled to run on that thread are now
blocked by this one go routine that's no
good
so this is mine thread periodically
checks if this bad situation is
occurring if it does it possibly
allocates a new thread with a new M
structure takes the P that was priorly
associated to m1 and says ok all these
go routines are now going to run on this
new thread pretty cool the system on
thread also checks for long running go
routines that need to be preempted
pretty plausible
however because preemption needs to play
nicely with the garbage collector
preemption can only happen at go
function entry so tight loops if you
just do a for loop forever can
potentially block arbitrarily this is a
bit hazardous swing go context switches
are fast by virtue of implementation
simplicity and not merely because
they're avoiding the round trip into
kernel space this is a design choice we
can support lots of concurrent go
routines like millions but we can't
assign them priorities we don't have
strong preemption guarantees and to
illustrate the practical effect of this
design decision I'd like to contrast
this implementation with Erlang Erlang
is also a language ostensibly designed
for highly concurrent programming in
early and concurrency primitives are
called processes but actually have
nothing to do with operating systems
processes except for the fact that they
do not share memory processors
communicate exclusively via asynchronous
message passing
so unlike go and see our link code is
actually compiled
by code and executed by a virtual
machine it's sort of like the JVM or C
Python or Ruby this architecture enables
a simple preemption mechanism which is
neither timer based like the Linux
kernel nor watcher based like go it uses
the notion of a reduction budget so
every Earling process when it is
scheduled gets a reduction count which
by default is about two thousand and
everything you do is going to cost you
reductions calling a function decrement
the reduction budget send a message to
another process same thing I Oh garbage
collection and once you use up your
reduction budget you get preempted this
is so simple that we can actually see it
in encode so the beam emulator source
code the Erlang virtual machine source
code is in C the core of emulator is
this gnarly 3700 line switch statement
it's got hella defines and go twos but
this is what matters if we want to call
a function the next byte code
instruction is going to say call a
function so we set the continuation
pointer advance the instruction pointer
to point to the next thing next byte
code instruction that we're going to
execute and then call a macro called
dispatch what does dispatch do it
dispatches if we still have reductions
in our budget we're going to decrement
the reduction counter and go through the
emulator loop for the next instruction
go back to the top of the switch
statement but if we're out of reductions
we're going to context switch so let's
take a moment to think through the
implications of this design so we knew
we have a reduction call a reduction
budget of about 2000 reductions and each
function call is going to cost us one of
those
how long do functions take not very long
normally this means we could be calling
into the scheduler at sub a millisecond
intervals scheduling is highly granular
what are the consequences the maximum
throughput of our program is going to be
affected if we just want to do lots and
lots of number crunching it's going to
be somewhat slower and
in a language like go but on the other
hands the preemption latency is highly
predictable it doesn't depend on the
scheduling of a separate operating
system thread or the prompt handling of
a timer
why does this matter let's try an
experiment this is a small go program
first we're going to spawn a bunch of
busy tight loops to saturate all the
cores on our machine I did this on my
laptop my laptop is four cars then we're
going to sleep for some predetermined
interval and measure how long we
actually slept versus how long we
expected to sleep this is a crude
estimate of the effective preemption
latency that our program is seeing when
the CPU is saturated by work does that
make sense so this is not a rigorous
benchmark I mean obviously you could
raise a lot of objections
yes I'm sorry thank you you should do
code review for me yes so so the jitter
is how long you actually slept versus
how long you expected to sleep and if
you run it you get a latency
distribution like this preemption
latency varies from sub millisecond to
up to 40 milliseconds it's compare this
with an implementation in Erlang it's
actually a lick sir
so elixir is a language that runs on the
Erlang VM its syntax is more Ruby like
so it doesn't make my brain hurt and if
you haven't read Erlang it probably
makes sense so we spawned a bunch of
busy tight loops to saturate the course
we sleep for some targeted amount and
then we measure how long we actually
slept for and use the difference between
that and our sleep target is an estimate
of preemption latency what does that
look like looks like this nearly
consistent sub-millisecond preemption
latency that's the difference
early trades some throughput for highly
predictable latency go does the opposite
yes
that's an excellent question the
question was whether it's significant
that the NGO functioning was calling
time that now and the elixir function
was bumping at counter you sir are an
amazing reader of code on slides yeah if
it's not significant the reason we're
calling time debt now and go is because
we need a Ingo in our tight loop we
actually need a function we actually
need to execute a function call because
if we just did for like increment the
counter we wouldn't call the scheduler
we totally dead lock it like like you
mentioned so it's it's not actually
significant I'm done I was like the
worst the first thing I thought of but
that's a great point so thank you for
bearing with me through this little
exercise maybe we've learned something I
certainly did scalable scheduling not
that mysterious all the implementations
that we saw saw us share some patterns
they use independent run queues with
periodic load balancing to scale well
across multiprocessor systems they
preempted safe points to prevent rogue
code from bringing things to a halt but
they make different design decisions the
Linux kernel scheduler gives you a very
granular priority system you can nice
your process to all sorts of different
things the go scheduler is very simple
no priorities at all and you can trade
latency predictability versus baseline
overhead coding go in general we'll run
a little bit faster than code in Erlang
because you are not paying this fairly
constant overhead costs for granular
scheduling but you may suffer greater
variance in latency in certain scenarios
and there are other trade-offs but these
are maybe the most salient that's all I
have thank you very much I would love to
take questions
yes
right that's a good question so the
question was what's the distinction
between context switching between native
threads and between green threads so it
depends a little bit on the language
runtime so when you in the linux kernel
and you switch between threads you do
need to save their registers in some
other thread State and switch that out
before for the next thing you're going
to execute because go code compiles to
native function calls the contact the
actual mechanics of the contacts which
are fairly similar use you save the
registers of the function you are in and
then switch to the next function in in
in a VM language like Erlang like the
actual registers on the machine are the
registers of the of the VM and and not
of the of your Erlang functions so so
that's sort of fundamentally different
but the actual mechanics are like quite
intrinsic and I can't really do justice
to them so I encourage you to use
something like F trace to you can sort
of pick apart the individual steps of
the context switch but it's it's like
quite hard to justify this
quantitatively but my opinion and it's
only an opinion is that the register
saving is a relatively small part of the
overall intrinsic cost of a context
switch and most of it is attributable to
the general complexity of of the
scheduler machinery
that is my opinion
but I don't have like don't don't take
that as truth because I can't really
give you a concise way that you could go
and prove this for yourself I mean a go
context which still takes 200
microseconds which is you know still
equivalent to a good a good chunk of
work yeah so the question was about
cache utilization which is you give in
general something that's quite difficult
to analyze convincingly but but my claim
is if your guru teens have a big working
set and you switch from go routine a to
go routine be like you're still going to
see cash penalties and if your threads
have a big working set and you switch
from thread a to switch thread B you'll
see big cash penalties like no matter
what the scheduler is doing but if the
working set is small that is not
necessarily the case so does that make
sense
go any other questions in the back
mhm
so the question was the reduction budget
is mm if you change that a number what
happens that's an excellent question so
what I would say to that is two things
so chain so changing the the reduction
budget changes the granularity obviously
if you double it you will see preemption
latencies on the order of two
milliseconds not one millisecond but it
doesn't change the predictability part
of the reason why there's a lot of
variance and go is because the
preemption is driven by a separate
operating system thread so preemption
latency is beholden to that operating
system thread being scheduled by the
operating system scheduled by the
operating system and there's hundreds of
milliseconds or not sorry not hundreds
of milliseconds but a few milliseconds
of latency variants there so it's
absolutely a like a sliding spectrum of
granularity versus preemption latency
does that make sense yes
yeah I'm honestly not entirely sure why
go light works like this but you can
call something like scheduled x' to
explicitly yield like pretty much every
runtime has a construct like that that
allows you to explicitly yields in a
tight loop yes
thank you very much so for I'm posterity
SiC the first comment was that in Erlang
if you basically call in to C extensions
the reduction count doesn't go down
unless you explicitly decrement it so it
is totally possible still to effectively
break the scheduler by calling C I mean
that sort of makes sense and the second
was about the paper that appeared a few
months ago called the Linux kernel
scheduler a decade of wasted cores that
paper was the catalysis for me proposing
this top to strangely but here's here's
what I think about it I'm not a systems
researcher so maybe I'm not really doing
it justice there are two parts to this
to that paper one is where they sort of
describe the general architecture of the
Linux CFS scheduler especially on
multi-core systems and I think it's a
fantastic exposition as for their claims
about wasted cores it seems to me like
the bugs that they found apply to
scheduling on Numa architectures with
lots of course like 64 core machines and
the the like regression cases that they
mentioned in that paper were things like
like running a ruby web server and also
compiling the Linux kernel or something
like that we're close that I personally
couldn't quite identify with real
workloads and I think I think like like
the paper is cool but if it had
represented a real improvement they
should have like posted it on the L KML
and like their patches should be in the
Linux kernel as far as I know like right
now they're not that could have changed
and like they they built some tools to
analyze scheduler performance but I
rather would have seen them leverage
more general purpose tools in the kernel
infrastructure like F tracer or perfs
good because like they they built their
own but you need a custom kernel and I'm
not hitting on the authors of the ad
paper but I think the like the things
that they found were relatively
special-purpose regressions and their
broader point that it's kind of a gnarly
piece of of code like obviously sans
it's like pretty complicated does that
seem reasonable cool I think we're out
of time but please come talk to me if
you think